hello everyone and welcome to round 17
of the 1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament after three consecutive wins
once again Fischer made two draws and
now he faces chess international master
from Argentina Jorge Alberto who Bonetti
who of course aside from being a very
strong chess player won the 1d
Argentinian Chess Championship four
times he represented Argentina eight
times in the Chess Olympiad and also
aside from qualifying for the intra
zonal tournament of 1990 17 Palma de
Majorca
he also qualified for 1982 inter zonal
tournament so it's a wonderful game and
it's a game actually that starts
Fischer's a legendary winning streak so
I do hope you're having a wonderful
Friday because this game will surely
improve it if you if you enjoy playing
against the Sicilian defense so before
we check out the game I do have a nice
photo challenge for you so who are the
two gentlemen in the photo here there
you have it the best of luck to everyone
I will also add a link to this photo in
the description below if you know you
want to check it out
on the source page so there you have it
now let's check out this wonderful game
Fischer has the white pieces like we've
said and he opens with E 4 we have c5
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures Knight
captures and the knight to f6 knife to
c3 and here is X is played going into
the show meaning and variation of the
Sicilian defense Bishop to c4 the sawsan
variation Fisher's favorite variation a6
and D mediate Bishop to b3 we have b5
and here although you might think ok
before is a threat you'd kick away the
defender of d4 pawn as this Knight is
attacking it one might play f3 here and
although f3 is a fine move Fischer
doesn't mind about this point rather he
plays castles here now there is a very
nice game I believe it's from the US
Championship of 1957 where Fischer
played played against James T Sherwin
were Sherman played before against him
and the official replied with a knife to
be won although it's a very nice game I
will put a link to it in the description
below if you want to check it out
but I will also put a link in the
description below from another guy it's
from the New Jersey open also from 1957
where Fischer played a beautiful game
against James T Sherwin it's also one of
the games from Bobby Fischer's my 60
memorable games I did a video on this
game so feel free to check that out as
well it will be in the description below
but better yet is this nice to a4 idea
now if Knight captures on e4 is played
then white can continue with this rook
to e1 move and after you block it of
course v5 defending the knight then
comes Bishop to f4 and here is the main
idea why this pawn can be sacrificed
after black continues development now
going for castles you can go Knight to
f5 and now you will either a block will
either castle and you will win the the
bishop repair wood tonight captors on e7
or if black even captures the knight
then you have this Queen captures on b5
a beautiful move threatening to capture
on f7 but also threatening the rook on
a8 and after Queen captures Bishop
captures blacks rook and a8 is under
attack if you don't want to lose rook of
course if you move the rook then Bishop
captures night so the best idea is g5
here Bishop to e5 now comes f6 defending
this rook and now Bishop to c7 after
Bishop to b7 you do have to give up
something as black simply captures rook
here captures any four rook captures on
c7 and rook captures on f5 this is only
one of the lines but this is one of the
lines were black plays the most precise
moves and at the end of this little
skirmish white will simply be up upon
and as I mentioned there is also the
game our fetcher played against the
James T Sherman were before was played
pressure replied Knight to be one which
was also a very nice game so before not
something you want to do so Fisher
doesn't mind he simply castles we have
Bishop to be seven and now rook to e1
and also again there's no way to
actually go for b4 here as now comes the
bishop to a4 check you block and now
Knight to d5
also this d5 square a very critical
Square when when fighting against the
Sicilian you can often sacrifice a
knight or even a bishop there and now
you will either capture with the bishop
and then all will be well or you will
continue the
helping how about if you captured an
pawn captures you have to block Knight
to a5 is coming
you have the castle and then Knight
captures would check and it will be a
much better made much better game for
white so almost never a good idea to
push this b4 pawn but a nice idea if
you're playing against the Sicilian to
know that before is not actually a real
threat it's okay Knight bt7
Bishop to g5 h6 now Bishop to h4 in the
night to c5 and now again we come to a
moment in this game it's only move 11
Fischer is about to make his 12th move
shows that Fischer is really up to you
know he's really into chest theory and
he knows the current advancements in
theory that have been made he plays
Bishop to d5 so offering a full piece
here and it's not the first time this
move has been played it was played in
1969 already by a couple flares one of
them being a Zoltan really so definitely
an interesting move and here if you you
probably should play something like
Queen to c7 to simply defend the bishop
here and allow this Bishop captures G
captures and Queen to f3 now attacking
the f6 pawn where white will have a
better game but in this game Ruby Nettie
decided to go for eeek a person d5 he
accepted the the P sacrifice Fischer
played he captures on d5 opening up a
discovered check from the rook to to the
King King d7 you don't want to block
with the bishop if you block with the
bishop dead then again you get Knight to
a5 and the white is completely winning
but II capture Sundy father now King to
d7 you wanna try and run away with your
king
here comes b4 knife to a 4 if you can
you are up a piece so why not trade even
more pieces Fischer doesn't mind Knight
captures pawn captures and what do you
do here how do you continue your attack
well simply c4 a very nice move
defending the d5 pawn and also preparing
Queen captures on a 4th there is no way
to stop Queen captures on a4 so here
Reuben Ettie simply started running with
his king we have Queen captures on e4
and now Queen to d7
offering a queen trade
as fisheries a down down of peace
although he does have a very nice pawn
chain he is down a piece of course he
does not want to trade queens who
intercede to is definitely an idea here
preparing to push c5 the queen is
already aligned with the king and the
sea fowl Knight f5 Bishop e3 all very
nice ideas here but Fischer goes for a
different idea he goes Queen to b3 and
now we have g5 butter up to g3 and here
Knight to h5 attacking Fisher's Bishop
and g3 but here a fish Rob simply
continues to push c5 threatening to open
up the sea file and then the rooks will
be able to get hold of the black king d
captures on c5 was played B captors on
c5 the threat of course now being c6
attacking the Queen and the bishop and
here there are really no good moves here
for black if you try and you know remove
one of the attackers as this Bishop and
g3 Fischer has is a monster piece really
controlling the black King so even if
you start with something like Nigeria c6
is coming the knight doesn't have any
useful in between moves Marshall
captures captures and after Queen moves
you will get this rook to e8 check the
King has nowhere to go you'd have to
block and now you can even capture the
Queen or even better Queen b7 deliver
checkmate
another thing after this big captors on
c5 threatening c6 you could try
something like Bishop capers on d5 to
attack the Queen but then pretty much
any move white will make will be will be
very nice Queen b6 now black has to make
a move the bishop is really controlling
all of the squares beautifully there's
no way to offer a queen trade there's no
good way to activate the rook so after
something like Queen b7 where black
would try to trade Queens you would
simply not allow him still you know keep
an eye on all the important squares and
after captures captures something like
Bishop to b4 whatever you play c6 is
coming there's no stopping c6 so
whatever you play c6 is coming you know
to open the lines and after Queen moves
of course if you capture with the bishop
then rook to see one but after Queen to
c7 now comes Queen to c3
eyeing that rook on h8 so whatever you
play here 25
rook captures any for for example Queen
characters and now rook to e1 Queen has
to move and now rook to e8 will of
course be deadly
King moves now comes rook captures any
eight eight and now it's actually white
who is up material if I'm not mistaking
why this up upon here but that is far
less important the black is you know
getting crushed here whatever you play
here
there's no no defense I mean there
there's no good move here for black so
whatever you play you will either go
into a nice endgame that you're you can
win easily or black will get checkmated
so here after be captures on c5 to stop
c6 Ruby Nettie tried Queen captures on
d5 he offering a queen trade here and
it's a very nice move now c6 doesn't
really work from this position but he
missed one move with that it does so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a winning idea for white
here and you know I will give it a
couple of seconds as usual if you want
to decide whether to do it so okay for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just started a
Bobby Fischer's legendary winning streak
and for those of you who just won't
enjoyed show here rook to e8 was played
what do you do here well there's only
one good move
you can block with the Queen of course
that's not a good move you lose the
Queen so King the d7 was played and now
comes Queen to a4 if you calculate it
all the way to here then it's very nice
but over to c6 blocking the only move
that doesn't lose the Queen and the now
comes Knight captures on c6 and it was
in this position I moved 24 that Jorge
Alberto Rubin 80 resigned the game it's
24 moves so I believe it counts as a
miniature what if he resigned well any
any continuation he goes for losses
terribly here if you capture the rook
then you get rook e1 check King moves
and now Knight to a7 opening up a
discovered check from the Queen I have
to remove the King rook e8 will be
checkmate the bishop once again very
nicely
guarding that a c7 square on the other
hand after Knight to c6 if you try Queen
captures on c6 of course you get a rogue
d1 check and now you have to move the
king and queen
actors on c6 you're getting checkmated
here with rook e1 check and again rook
to e8 will be checkmate and lastly after
all this is said you can even play rook
captures here but then the the very
simple night before check wins the Queen
and the game the queen is attacked the
king is in check if you work with the
Queen the night is also guarding c6 so
or not a lot of thing you can do here
you can try and protect the Queen with
the King which is a bit silly but you
know why not but even here first you
will lose the Queen after King moves you
will get check here and then you will
get checkmate it in very very soon so
Knight captures and c6 Ruby Nettie
resigned the game and a beautiful
victory in round 17 against the Sicilian
for Bobby Fischer so that's the game
runs 17 of form of the American 1970
inter zonal tournament I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Anton
baklanov
Sonya shinnok and Scott Adams for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with the Bobby Fischer series
and perhaps if we you know have
something like happen out of the
ordinary in the chess world but yeah
that's pretty much it and see you soon